hey CEO this is Tate from Atlanta what
up Tate thanks for calling in brother I
appreciate it
first off sorry I found a extra life
today I'm a little stuffy I'm getting
over a cold so maybe don't stand to fuss
too close to the phones I don't want to
get you sick bruh but anyways I wouldn't
solve that new jerker movie last night
oh yeah then we're gonna see it tomorrow
actually
and I love face pain anyway let's hear
more it was pretty good but uh I know
all the news outlets and all were
reporting that people might want to be
aware that these in cells might be there
those movie premieres inciting violence
and all that I was level what's an in
cell so I looked at often its
involuntary celibates is just like
internet group of dudes who can't get
any action and take it out on women
because they think that it's their
problem somehow and and I was wondering
what are your thoughts on that that's
just kind of weird to me I think it's a
weird culture we live in and the
internet forums and all that can breathe
them there's some really weird monster
people you know so uh yeah anyway
appreciate it of what you're doing
oh thanks man thank you for us sorry I
can gang stay safe out there men gang
bra stay safe too and it is Halloween
month so it's like time of year where
somebody will you know dress up like a
giraffe and hit you with a hatch at her
son you know for no reason and just say
they were looking for candy or whatever
no get off scot-free because these
attorneys in all this [__] but yet
they're in Cellular's I don't do it you
know I think there's a lot of soft batch
people out there now there's a lot of
guys that struggle you know if you
struggle to meet women and struggle to
you know converse with women and
struggle to form relationships that's
one that's one thing but if you find you
have a real anger towards women you know
that's something else you got to deal
with you can't be dressing you know you
can't be dressing up like you know like
Christopher Robin's or whatever and
you know throwing you know throwing like
wooden swords and [__] at like local
[__] in your area that's you know
that's not that kind of that's that's no
way to you know it's almost we're
heading into the holidays I mean Jesus
so I don't and also the news I don't
believe anything news says I really
don't know
I don't believe ever since remember when
they said that about the election before
they had the presidential election
they're like Oh Hillary's gonna win this
much and all the all the polls they had
done and and then they were just wrong
they were just wrong about everything
and at that point I realized oh the news
it used to be like fax and now it's just
people guessing [__]
with cameras so I think the movies going
to be fine I think the news is just
trying to scare people you know I think
there's some guys out there but they're
tightening up that's what I think and
things are looking up have a little bit
of red meat maybe or has some strong
broccoli you know do something eat a
half at that you know drink half a thing
of [__] Elmer's you know do something
tighten up and feel strong I think
there's a lot of young men that are
feeling stronger than ever you know it's
like the news is always say you know
does racism and this Annette wrote when
I was in Pittsburgh for the game today I
saw so much like non racism probably
more than I've ever seen and I was like
oh yeah once again everything's going
fine now I don't think I don't think
it's a bad idea to stay strapped if you
need to these days wherever you're going
you know if they have a legal law where
you can carry a weapon I don't think you
need to be alarming people like my
cousin Jamie and he would you know he
popped out from behind the computer you
know the computer desk with two guns on
him and he was in his underpants and so
he Jesus Christ dude and he has a
deviated septum and had to listen to him
snore for probably
I can't even tell you it sounded like a
couple of whales trying to meet each
other and you know one of like a very
distant Beach but I don't know I'm
talking about man but I'll say this bro
you got to take care of yourself dude
tighten up and keep tightening up that's
what you can do that's what you can do
and look have a plan if you do have
don't don't be the jackoff that's
sitting in the movie with no plan you
know going there have a little bit of a
plan no matter what have an escape plan
you know if you're going in with your
girl you know where heart you know do
something have a little shield or
something do something just have a
little plan but I think overall that
things are everything's gonna be okay I
don't think things are getting that
squirrelly but then also if they have
people that are in cells dude I don't
know I guess we'll be I guess well I
guess we'll beat them somehow you know
we will defeat them when it all goes
down that's what I'm hoping and I'm
gonna go see the movie tomorrow and I'm
gonna get some damn Milk Duds or
whatever dude or some jujubes and chill
and I think a lot of these in cellular
fellow's are a lot of them probably are
men that feel you know they don't they
feel so probably anger towards women you
know there's bent there was a movement
and I don't know if it's still as heavy
as it was but where a lot of women were
just being mean towards men you know
just being mean you know and they were
kind of using the guise of feminism but
really just being this mean and a lot of
times it's like lonely women and writing
these articles about how bad men are and
they're just lonely why don't just write
an article it says hey I'm you know what
and sometimes I'm lonely
dude everybody could really relate to
that article but just being a real bi
TCH with a pen because you are lonesome
sometimes that's not super helpful miss
you know and so I think a lot of these
men that are attacking women sometimes
they feel they feel attacked probably
and I'm not saying it's right you know
you're not supposed to hit a woman but
also a lot of women these days they're
not these aren't the same women from
fifty years ago when a woman you know
was due they didn't have gymnasiums and
they didn't have you know women weren't
doing a lot of you know strength
training and you know throwing all axes
and all of this or throwing you know big
leg you know pushing sled let and now
you have it's dude they got dude a buddy
of mine his wife hit him with a car so
he can't hit her when he can't punch her
in the shoulder one time so what is the
rule then what is going on there you
know I mean his wife hit him with a damn
LeSabre not the AH sort of Buick so what
you can't he can't tight you know he
can't rattle one off one time or put her
in a you know a rear naked choke for 30
seconds just there's got to be some
rules sometimes but I don't just think
for sheer anger you can just be
attacking women out in the street that's
not going to help anything so but this
makes me think about pornography man
I've been struggling with the dark arts
brother I'll be honest with you uh you
know about three months ago I have this
blocker on my phone that keeps
pornography off and it it's somehow the
it updater didn't update and next thing
you know man the whole just I mean
Satan's just it's just like Satan's
belly button opened up it was like he
was a pinata and his belly button just
opened up and just started spilling
dirty candies all over me so I've been
struggling with a little bit of that and
I turned on some blockers they have on
the iPhone they're like innate blockers
built into the system you know natural
blockers that Apple has but I want to
get that full throttle and get back to
the thing that I had going on before
or so but just a timing I'm not an
insult I don't think but you know I'm
kind of in and out sell like I'm in and
then I'm out I'm out and then I mean
sometimes I feel you know like I'm okay
sometimes I feel like I'm not I think
I'm just
cellular that's what I am I'm not in
cellular I'm not out cellular really I'm
just cellular we all are you know that's
the building blocks of us that's what
they said or that's Adams maybe what did
you enjoy that clip well you really
would have enjoyed if he was watching on
a TCL TV TCL is America's fastest
growing TV brand it's so fast it's the
Carl Lewis of television brands it's
that Florence Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its 5th anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com